getting out of this abandoned mine is a
back-breaking climb a well-organized
production line runs from deep under the
Earth's surface into the light
but it's all illegal and is often raided
by police
coal is a Lifeline for these men and
women most of these communities are not
connected to the energy grid and have
high levels of unemployment it's
something that we use to let to survive
on you know so it's very much important
for us because it's what we are using
you know as a primary source of of
hitting our homes because of load
shedding and energy poverty it's a
situation that you know our province is
facing that as much as we are generating
electricity we don't have electricity
load shedding is the term for South
Africa's state-ordered power outages
ongoing for 16 years due to a
combination of rundown facilities
corruption and sabotage boomalanga hosts
12 coal fuel power plants and countless
mines it's earned this province the
title of one of the most polluted
regions in the world
has two children and both have breathing
issues and she's convinced her eldest
daughter severe asthma is caused by the
suffocating air here this cold kills us
Bali says princess is always much better
when they visit family outside the
province here she often needs a
nebulizer a pretty medication inside
when it's a little when you have
electricity
living side by side not benefiting from
the power these plants generate and
suffering from its emissions reports
that we've released have found that
there is a link to cardiovascular
disease neurological diseases so people
are suffering from heart attacks Strokes
as a result of the air pollution the
pollution is also linked to around 3 300
premature deaths a year activists won a
case against the government last year
with the Pretoria High Court ruling that
the air quality here was essentially a
human rights violation it gave
authorities 12 months to come up with a
plan to improve emissions well that
deadline passed in March and so far
little has changed Thomas was part of
that case he says the state-owned power
companies try to cut Corners by asking
for extensions to comply with limits we
also need to understand that our biggest
pollutants in the country is Sasol and
eskom and eskom being a state-owned
entity I don't think government wants to
fight one of their own he tells us that
parents here are raising a generation of
sick children sometimes I even think
that maybe one day I'll lose my child
because of this air pollution
there is little they can do to change
their fate that will take money and
ultimately political will Stephanie
Decker Al Jazeera bumbalanga Province
South Africa